this strife in the strait of hormuz is
creating a gulf between the US and its
European allies there's a debate to put
it mildly there's a debate about this
between Europe and America new u.s.
acting defense secretary mark Esper will
spend his first days on the job at nato
headquarters trying to convince his
European counterparts their own
interests are at stake in the street to
US ambassador to NATO kay Bailey
Hutchison has been laying the groundwork
it's not a NATO function but around
attacking ships and saying that they're
going to go back into preparing for
nuclear weapons that's pretty strong
we've gotta stand up to it but Esper is
still likely to have a tough time
getting European support for military
action one of the problematic parts of
trumps agenda from the very beginning is
this idea of basically every nation
fighting for itself in a kind of arena
of actors that's the way some of the
people around Trump put it in the
beginning of his term so so I mean in my
view that doesn't work then there's the
u.s. president's casual linkage of
article 5 all allies solemn
responsibility to defend each other to
how much they spend on their militaries
now there is article 3 which states that
all governments should continually and
effectively improve their capabilities
and to be sure some don't but never
before has the commitment to collective
defence been quantified or questioned
Europeans are spending more on their
militaries now and will spend even more
in the future but rather than easing
tensions with the US a new front has
been opened that's because the European
Union is earmarking almost 600 million
dollars for its own defence projects
that might exclude the u.s. Washington
is threatening to retaliate still senior
NATO officials believe things will work
out because the US and European defense
industries are already intertwined so I
think all together the picture is not so
much that of a fortress America of a
fortress Europe but that of
transatlantic market that is in place
and that from this perspective is likely
to continue and in its quest to convince
Europeans to ratchet up pressure on Iran
the u.s. may take heart from recent
history it took years but all allies now
agree with the u.s. conclusion that
Russia is violating the
intermediate-range nuclear treaty the
INF they also support the u.s. decision
to declare the treaty dead on August 2nd
unless Moscow announces it will destroy
its program before then a unanimous NATO
stance that once seemed impossible to
achieve
Terri's will start reporting there and
we can take you now to Terry in Brussels
where she is still at the NATO HQ good
to see you Terry
let's pick up where that report left off
with the end of that landmark arms
control pact between the US and Russia
looming in the back ground
what are ministers advocating where you
are do they want to beef up a defense or
do they want to try and bring Russia
back into the fold
officially Leyla ministers are still
giving Russia until August 2nd to come
back into compliance which would mean
destroying this massive expensive
missile system and nobody thinks that's
going to happen but they definitely want
to be seen as giving every last chance
to the Kremlin there's expected to be a
NATO Russia meeting next week so that at
least NATO can say look we tried until
the very last minute not to abrogate
this treaty not to have this treaty
declared to defunct at the same time
they're saying they have to look at what
a post INF world looks like a world
without controls on intermediate-range
nuclear weapons and that is going to
mean beefing up NATO's own defenses
there is a missile defense system in
NATO it would have to be reconfigured to
look at the new threat coming from
Russian missiles that then could be
trained on European countries so it's a
really big deal here and and people are
quite nervous about it but we won't be
hearing much about the options until
after the INF is declared dead on August
2nd in the probable case that Russia
doesn't come into compliance and Terry
that isn't the only
a foreign policy issue causing concern
where you are of course the escalating
tensions between us and Iran I imagine
are front and center there as well
what's NATO's position and have European
members of the Alliance expressed where
they stand NATO doesn't have a position
on Iran it doesn't even want to have to
take a position on Iran at the moment it
says this is between the u.s. and Tehran
and it very much hopes for a
de-escalation nobody wants to see a war
in the Gulf especially complicated for
European Union members who are still
trying to keep the nuclear deal together
with Tehran so de-escalation of tensions
is definitely the first priority but
we've just seen us acting defense
secretary mark Esper arrived and have
some remarks with Secretary General
Stoltenberg he is definitely trying to
give allies the impression that he is a
supporter of NATO he has served in NATO
posts and he wants to reassure allies
that the u.s. is not going to take any
rash actions at the same time we just
heard the UK defense secretary come in
and she said look we are very much in
favor of de-escalation we don't want to
see any military action there Europeans
are in are definitely not in favor of
escalation at the same time again if
they're saying it's a u.s. Iran issue
they really don't have that much
leverage over Washington but Mark Esper
is going to be updating allies in just
the next couple of hours and I believe
that Washington will be trying to
reassure them that nothing is going to
happen without consultation Terry so
Schultz in Brussels thank you for your
continued coverage